يعد رالي داكار احد اشهر سباقات السرعه في
العالم والاكثر متعه واثاره نظرا للطرق
المستخدمه فيه ونوعيه المركبات والدراجات
الداخليه في المسابقات السباق هو من
الانشطه الرياضيه القليله عالميا التي
تفتح ابوابها للمحترفين والهواه ليس ذلك
فحسب بل يشكل الهواتف نحو 80% من
المتسابقين الرالي الشهير احد اطول
اراليات واكثرها استمراريه على مدى الايام
المتواصله حيث يستمر لنحو 14 يوما يخوض
فيه المتسابقون منافساتهم بطرق متعدده
منها الرملي والطيلي والصخري كذلك الجبليه
داكار بدا في اوله كسباق يمر بين العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس والعاصمه السنغاليه دبكه
لكنه تغير مع الايام واصبح يقام في مناطق
مختلفه حيث اقيم سابقا بين الارجنتين
وتشيلي ومره بدول عربيه مثل الجزائر وتونس
وايضا مصر ليصل الى تنظيمه الكلي الى
السعوديه بدءا من عام 2020 واستمرارا حتى
2030 في شراكه تاريخيه مع السباق الابراز